JOANNE STUBBE: When I went
to graduate school, which
was in the late
1960s, I didn't even
know what an enzyme was,
because back in those days
I'd never had a biology course.
They didn't do biochemistry
back in those days.
And I think I heard a lecture
by Van Tamelen at Stanford.
He was interested in
steroid structures, steroids
that have four rings and it's
the basis for sex hormones
and for cholesterol
biosynthesis.
They're all sort of made through
a common biosynthetic pathway
that we don't really talk about.
These are these
five carbon units
to form carbon-carbon bonds
that I mentioned earlier.
Anyhow, what he
showed was you could
take 30 carbon strung
together in a linear form.
And then somehow
these 30 carbons
folded up with one enzyme
to form these four rings,
putting in eight asymmetric
centers in a single step at pH7
in 100% yield.
Once I saw that, I said man
I don't want to be a chemist.
If you could see how
nature designed this,
and what is the basis for being
able to make these molecules,
it was sort of mind
boggling to me.
And I think enzymes
are like that.
What they do is they've
evolved for billions of years
to accelerate rates of reactions
by factors as much as 10
to the 20th.
So that's really fast,
like a bat out of hell.
And so nature has figured out
how to control all of this.
But again, she has
a limited repertoire
of reactions that she catalyzes,
but she's extremely good at it.
And so understanding people
have studied enzymes forever
because I'd like to understand
the basic principles
of catalysis.
And then if you
understood those,
can the chemist then
take this understanding
and translate it into
the bigger repertoire
of the periodic table
you have to be able to do
these transformations?
So the mechanisms of
rate acceleration,
which we talk about in some
detail in a lecture, what
causes these catalysts
to work, and the way you
describe how these
catalysts work.
It doesn't matter
whether you're using
a small inorganic molecule
or small organic molecules
or a protein, the
basic principles
and thinking about catalysis is
exactly the same, except nature
has figured out how to do this
better than anything man can
do.
But again, she's
limited in terms.
She's had a billions of years
to evolve these catalysts,
but then she's limited in
the repertoire of reactions
that she needs to catalyze.
So how can you not
think enzymes are cool?